- But I heard one time
that you were on like
I guess theater, you were doing theater,
and you fell asleep on stage.
(Jon laughs) Like your character
is supposed to be asleep,
but you actually fell asleep.
- Yes, I fancy myself a
very professional actor.
- Do you? (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- But apparently that's not true.
No, I was, one of my very first jobs
was in a Broadway show called
"Brighton Beach Memoirs."
It's a wonderful Neil Simon play.
- Yeah, yep.
(audience applauds)
- An amazing, amazing writer.
And my character had to
fall asleep at one point.
He had to go upstairs and
go to sleep in his room.
But you have not experienced
terror until you realize
that you fell asleep
during the Broadway show
you're starring in. (chuckles) Um.
Oh my goodness, 'cause I remember
there was an actor named Joe
Breen who, wonderful actor,
who was in, he was in "Galaxy Quest."
And I remember just laying
there and he was sleeping,
he was sleeping across from me,
but he is a better actor
who fakes it, apparently.
(Kelly laughs)
And I remember him,
and I remember just the
look on his face going,
"Jon, Jon, Jon."
And his eyes got all huge.
And then I was like,
"Huh, I wonder what's,
I wonder what Joe's, what his problem is."
- What's your problem? (laughs)
- Exactly. And then, the
adrenaline shot of all time
went through my body
because I realized I was,
I had fallen asleep during the
play that I was supposed to.
But thankfully, if you rehearse
enough, it's muscle memory.
So, I leapt in, and the
monologue that I had to say,
thankfully, leapt into
my mouth, but that--
- Well, you had a nap.
You should have felt fresh. (laughs)
- You're right. (laughing)
- Should have felt real fresh.
- Yes, you're right, you're right.
- There's nothing more terrifying
'cause I grew up in musical
theater of being on stage
and going, "Why is everyone quiet?"
- [Jon] Yes! (laughing)
- And they're quiet because
it's your turn to say something.
- Yep.
- Yeah.
- Yep, exactly, exactly.
- That's when I knew the
theater was not for me.
(Jon laughs)
But anyway, but I heard that,
were you fired from that play?
And was it because you fell asleep?
- No.
- Okay.
- Interestingly, I was
fired before I fell asleep.
(audience laughing)
So that.
- Wow!
- Yeah, no, no,
I was actually Matthew
Broderick's understudy
for a long time.
Well, not for that long
'cause they fired me.
But, but no, it was, that
was my first, first gig.
I was like, I was 18 and I was terrified.
And Matthew is a wonderful,
wonderful performer.
He was the lead in the show.
It was his breakout role.
He won the Tony for it.
And so I was terrified.
And they fired me right
after he won the Tony.
I think because they wanted somebody
that people had heard of in the show
taking over for him as opposed to me.
But it was a very formative
experience in my life
because all of my, my
parents are performers,
and all of their actors friends
really gathered around me
because this is the kind of thing,
this happens to actors all the time.
And how you react to it really...
- [Kelly] Which one, shows who you are.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and I did the
most constructive thing,
which was to vow revenge.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- You know what though? Sometimes
that's fuel for your fire.
- It was, actually; I did
not prove vow revenge.
- I'll prove to you like why
you should have picked me
for that, yeah.
- Exactly.